نحدث عن دخول الشهر الرابع لهذا القتال لا
تزال مدينتا خان يونس و وغزه بطبيعه الحال
تشهدان اعنى في المعارك الميدانيه ولكن لا
تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره رغم كل
ذلك على
ضرب خارج قطاع غزه اذا ما دخلنا الى
المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه نتحدث عن
محاور للقتال البري هجوما ودفاعا ونتحدث
ايضا عن صواريخ لا تزال تطلق من قطاع غزه
وعلى ما يبدو انها من المنطقه الشماليه
باتجاه مست نات غلاف غزه ديروت نير عام عل
ميم وناح العز ضربت اليوم من قبل سرايا
القدس في عده رشاقات صاروخيه وفق ما اعلن
الجارح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي اذا
ما دخلنا الى داخل قطاع غزه نتحدث عن
عمليات عسكريه مكثفه للجانبين للجيش
الاسرائيل الذي قال في اكثر من مناسبه
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه انه يركز
عملياته الان في حيي التفاح والدرج ولكن
في المقابل تقول المقاومه الفلسطينيه انها
تضرب هذه القوات المتوغلة
استهدفت قوات اسرائيليه كما شاهدنا بمقطع
الفيديو ايه ب حشودا عسكريه في منطقه
القرم التي تقع في هذه المنطقه غربي مدينه
جباليا او حي جباليا البلد نتحدث عن
المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه اذا لازال
نتحدث عن عمليات عسكريه مكثفه للقوات
الاسرائيليه في المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع
غزه ولا نزال تتحدث ايضا عن قدره القوامه
الفلسطينيه على ضرب هذه القوات المتوغلة
القوات الاسرائيليه تضرب هذه المناطق بقوه
رغم الدمار الكبير لا تزال المقاومه قادره
على ضرب مستوطنات غلاف غزه ويخرج
المقاتلون ليستهدف الاليات العسكريه
المتوغلة
وغل في المنطقه الشرقيه من مخيم البريج
هذه تطورات يمكن القول انها خفيفه نسبيا
مع الايام المقارنه في الايام الماضيه في
المنطقه الوسطى ولكن الضغط الكبير تشهده
المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه ومدينه
خانيونس بطبيعه الحال رغم ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ حوالي اكثر من شهر حاول
التوغل الى خان يونس الا انه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يستطع الوصول الى قلب مدينه خان
يونس والتوغل داخل البلده القديمه فيها
يعت الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان خانيونس هي
مركز عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه يقول انه
يضغط بشكل كبير في المنطقتين الشماليه
الشرقيه والشماليه المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
المقابل ركزت عملياتها خلال الساعات
الماضيه على منطقتي الزنه وخزاعه الزن
هناك مجموعه من الاستهدافات لاليات وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
جله او الاليات العسكريه المتوغلة
سطرته على القاطع الشمالي لمدينه خان يونس
ولكنه يقول ايضا انه بدا العمليه العسكريه
لخان يونس من الجهه الجنوبيه لكنه يقول ان
الجهه الجنوبيه والجهه الغربيه من خان
يونس تحتاج اشهر لانه هناك تركيز لقوه
كتائب القسام في هاتين المنطقتين المنطقه
الجنوبيه او المنطقه الغربيه من خانيونس
بحسب ما يقول الاحتلال او جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يركز الجيش الاسرائيلي على ان
المعضله الان التي تواجهه في خانيونس هي
معضله الانفاق اي انه يقول ان هناك ثواني
معدودات ل الجنود الاسرائيليين ليضربوا
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين الذين يخرجون من
عيون الانفاق يضربون القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
كيلومتر من الجهه الشماليه الى الى الجنوب
هذا المربع الذي يسعى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للسيطره عليه توغل في اطرافه من الجهه
الشرقيه والشماليه والجهه الغربيه ولكنه
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يستطع الوصول الى قلب
خانيونس كما ذكرنا اذا هذه الطبيعه
الجغرافيه الاولى في خانيونس عمران وكثافه
عمرانيه عاليه ولكن في المناطق الاخرى اذا
ما شاهدنا مثلا في خزاعه وفي الزنه هناك
مناطق واسعه من الفراغات التي تسمح
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بفتح عيون انفاق
جديده لشبكه الانفاق الكبيره والهائل التي
يقول الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انه يسعى
للسيطره عليها خان يونس ولكنه يحتاج الى
اشهر واشهر طويله للسيطره على كامل مدينه
خان يونس وهو يواجه مقاومه شرسه وفق ما
يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه المعلومات
بطبيعه الحال ستحتاج الى تحليل وستكون معك
جمال اليك شكرا